I have a great recollection
I remember when I
Ottawa and I was looking to do studies
in psychology and Judaism and religion
and I went to see a professor at the
University and he asked me that I hear
of a Viktor Frankl I said no he said
well you may be interested in him okay
he as a matter of fact he had just been
there a month ago some was he had turned
out to have been there a month ago so I
said okay so he had written a book and
he asked me to go buy it I went to buy
it I read it and I said this is
incredible it's almost as if this fellow
has been inside the the mindset of
Jewish religious leaders over the
generations and has sovereign Malcolm a
didn't turn into a psychological system
so I immediately said I have to get in
touch with him so I called the publisher
of the book in in New York I said sorry
we don't give out his address fine but
you could send us a letter we'll send it
over to him fine
so I sent a letter went over to them a
few months later I'm sitting in the
kitchen the phone rings and in those
days the operators they announced - it
was on the other end and they said on
the other hand there's a Frankel from
Europe calling no idea what this is
turned out it was dr. Viktor Frankl
himself and why was he calling he was
calling to tell me that he was coming to
America and that if he had if I have
time I'd love to meet him so for me it
was the middle of my studies on this
because I had taken a little bit further
and read everything that he had written
in English so I said great so I said
where you gonna be so I've been out of
what he said I'm gonna be in Rochester
which is it's about five hour drive but
he want me he said it's I'm a very tight
schedule I'll have five minutes for you
all right I have five minutes fine so we
get into the car I Drive all the way out
to Rochester and we meet and I'm looking
at the clock seconds five minutes I
gotta be care
you know what are you gonna say in five
minutes it turned out that that we spent
the better part of an afternoon evening
together
five minutes turned out to be four hours
and that was the most lasting impression
that to this very day I have of a person
who valued his time but then he spent it
so liberally when it was for something
that he felt was we should use that word
meaningful interestingly at during that
conversation I found out that he
absolutely hated to go to cocktail
parties because these are just a waste
of time with small talk and all this
stuff and then I just opposed that with
the conversation I had with him for four
hours which was the beginning of a
lifelong friendship and turned out
interestingly enough that there were a
lot of things that were happening that I
wasn't even aware of
including the poll that was being
exerted upon him by people within other
religious domains for logotherapy to
sort of be embraced by them and so this
was like a welcome opportunity to say
well to use his words to say to somebody
like Tweety you want low low growth area
to be Christian but polka says it's
Jewish
it's I would say complicated it not he's
not an easy individual because he didn't
fit into any conventional sense into
anything how do you explain an
individual who when you sit down with
him he takes a pen and he starts to
doodle and in five minutes he's giving
you a profile of yourself that's as
accurate as it comes
you know it's an individual who you know
just thinks differently than than others
he he had a passion about logotherapy
not being misunderstood this is
something that I saw in him all the time
nothing bothered him more than people
who would take a statement and out of
context or would distort what
logotherapy is and it bothered him
because this really was his baby
Rollo may wrote a piece in the Journal
of humanistic psychology in which he
accused bloggers sort of logotherapy of
being authoritarian so for whatever
reason I decided I was gonna write a
response I'm fine
so I wrote the response and not only
that but the journal sent a copy of it
to dr. Frankel just on the off chance
that he may want to write a response to
my response which he did and this was
quite quite interesting because in the
end apparently they actually met and
Rollo makes what I understand actually
admitted that he didn't fully understand
local therapy and I don't know if he
went so far as to apologize but it
became good friends which is nice but it
was then that I could sense that he was
very much bothered by this because to
say a psychological system is
authoritarian is the kiss of death so it
needed to be defended
weaknesses I think his Marana Klee won
his strength probably was also at the
same time his weakness in in the sense
that he was so protective of logotherapy
that some sometimes got him down maybe a
little bit overprotective I'm not sure
it's it's hard to say about an
individual like that you know that that
it's I'm not even sure it's appropriate
to use the word weakness it's something
that it's taught him well but also could
get him in into trouble because
sometimes if you're too quick to defend
and you're too quick to to rise up in
anger against something that you don't
like and maybe there may be one or two
times that he did lose his his cool but
I don't necessarily think that getting
angry is a is a weakness if if it's a
controlled anger and I mean he didn't
get angry over petty stuff that's that's
for sure so the stuff he got angry about
was stuff that was worth getting angry
over
our
deepened all the time he asked me when
the time would come god forbid that if I
would come to Vienna to preside at his
funeral well I sort of said to him I'll
agree to it as long as you don't die
immediately and he did live a quite a
long time after after that and the way
things worked out because of the
pressures that were being exerted
apparently he was very quite quickly so
I never got a chance to fulfill that but
I've sort of felt it was like a promise
that I had made that I hadn't fulfilled
so we did get a little bit later the at
the cemetery when you raised the
monument and here too was something
quite interesting lesser people have had
great monuments built to them what does
he have there basically it's a it's a
small it's a small little stone which is
actually superimposed upon another one
because he was proud of the tradition
that he came from and what did he always
use this analogy about the fact that he
could see further because he's standing
on the shoulders of giants he actually
carried that through in the way that he
was buried that he's buried basically on
the shoulders of another of another
monument not one standing on his own
it's quite fitting